this is a production of Cornell
University keeping what this year's is
the third week of our sports turf
webinar as always we'll start with dr.
Rossi he'll give us a little bit of an
overview what the current situation is
growing season wise you know we might
get some perspective on the COBIT
situation short restrictions minimum
maintenance things like that and then
we're joined by dr. raucous why out of
the universe University of Nebraska
probably one of the most published and
accomplished researcher you're going to
find out here so I'm sure that'll be a
great conversation we'll have some great
discussions on cultivation and certainly
many different topics at the end of this
so uh you know Frank I'll turn over to
you for the record Rock I didn't put him
up there I didn't put him up to it he
looked to your fro I haven't done a CV
in probably 10 years anyway thank you
very much for joining us and as you can
tell we're gonna have a very lively
conversation when we get the rock in a
minute Carl can you hear me okay yeah
all right all good good all right so
again welcome welcome to another week of
this this is our third week of doing it
thank you for joining us and for those
of you watching it on you know on
recording welcome as well
Brian winkin did a wonderful job and a
recent tweet I'm a big fan of Brian's
we've done a podcast together talking
about hit that initial concept him in
munch aw were working on called blue
muta posted something on his Twitter
account that really says it all and I
have to say in the northeastern United
States this is exactly what it's been
like for the last several years never
mind just April and then to only maybe
get a good stretch of weather and to
have to feel close for the current
situation so will I will try to distract
you for the next thirty minutes we'll be
pretty close to trying to get this done
so you can get onto the other things
that are important in the day so just a
message from your land-grant institution
here in New York and I know my colleague
at the land-grant institution and in
great state of Nebraska has the same
mindset that right now we need to
support each other and the best
universities and learning centers can do
is to try to collaborate with each other
because solutions will come about and
and Rock knows me well enough to know I
I think I know a lot but I know enough
to know I I know barely anything and
that's why it's great to have the
collaborators join us and we've had a
long list of really good scientists
thanks again to Rock for joining us so
we have our weekly newsletter in
addition to us yakking here on on the
computer we've been writing this up now
I've been journaling the growing seasons
for the last 21 years and if you'd like
to get a copy of this we're covering
topics more in depth in writing and then
echoing it in the webinar so you're
getting a double dose of our mind set in
a way we're thinking about approaching
it here at Cornell well I have to say
Pam Sherrod in the sports turf program
at Ohio State to me in many ways is the
gold standard of a program that you know
comprehensively addresses sports field
management I put goalies program
certainly in Iowa State's program and
you know Rock knows these programs very
well over the years and Pam did a
wonderful job of putting together this
ten maintenance practices to focus on
during this particular issue and and I
think the first thing is she mentions
and I commend this to you Carla put the
link up to these bodies to these
resources that we cite during the
webinar and the things that Rock and I
talked about but first and foremost you
know in many ways Golf Course
superintendent's are having to deal with
this grounds managers are having to deal
with it then sports field managers
having to deal with it
restricting the use of your turf grass
areas you can't use it we keep it for
you to use but right now for whatever
reason you can't use it for you the
activity is restricted the liability
insurance we're not going to maintain it
you name it
in my mind a lot of the work of sports
field managers Falls first and foremost
on managing your facility keeping people
safe your workforce safe and of course
the users of the facility safe now
what's really interesting in New York
State we have you know thinking about
universities and school districts we
have the New York state school
facilities management Institute that
recently did a survey for those of you
that are joining from school districts
wondering that sports fields or
municipalities or larger facilities run
by the state they did a survey which
says which statement best describes your
current operations and it they got 80
responses which I thought was actually
pretty good probably 10% 15% of the of
the staff the school district staff
anyway so there's some the majority of
them have limited maintenance and
performing just building checks and just
emergency stuff a few of them have no
maintenance staff on-site and I don't
really know how much of this relates to
sports fields but it's some data locally
on on removing some of the confusion
about what other facilities are doing
with regard to their sports fields
surely the majority of activities that a
lot of our fields would be used for
intentionally is not happening a lot of
those things are not allowed now every
place I look I see that people are
having to break up these sorts of things
so they are happening to some degree so
again it adds to the confusion about how
you approach managing your fields at
this time well here at Cornell we got a
hard decision everybody's gone
everybody's gone every we're good okay
all right every we got a hard situation
well a hard line we know exactly what's
happening the kids are gone there's no
sports and no one's going to be using
this place until mid-july so are our
athletic our sports turf manager Josh
Fontaine put together a minimum action
plan for kovat and we're sending it to
the athletic department we're making
everybody aware of the kinds of things
that we're doing including including the
impact on labor hours right this is
something that everyone is having to
deal with now we're really fortunate
because between Carl and Josh we've been
in Chris Citgo our other sports field
management expert we've developed sort
of how long does it take to do things
for the way our fields are set up and
the way we manage these things and so we
know on our acreages are natural grass
acreages that we're caring for the labor
so I'd encourage you opera
racially to start thinking about these
sorts of things depending on how long
this goes the pressure we get to rehire
people to return to normal or the
pressure we get to stay closed
communicating the impact on what's
possible and what you can do you know it
doesn't Rock and I are gonna talk about
soil management in a minute you're not
doing any soil management if there's one
guy on 15 acres ok so first what do you
need to do certain things and again Pam
and the folks at the V I'm sorry the
Ohio State University I forgive me for
not bringing that up to begin with you
know talks about mowing what's needed
and you know they've got regional
differences their fungicide applications
only if disease is active we don't have
anything active in the northeast we got
barely any mowing going on north of a
certain line we'll look at in a second
and then finally don't be putting on
quick-release sources if you don't have
traffic right you're trying to slow
growth to some degree now this is gonna
be dependent on how much passive traffic
you're getting a lot of people are as
busy as they've ever been because people
are just walking around all over the
place and you have to determine how much
access people have to your sports fields
so let's look at some weather among my
favorite things to do right so this is
what it was last week when we met and
you can see that the 50 degree mark was
barely into South Jersey and now it
looks like we're in the mid to low 50s
into the Hudson Valley onto Long Island
it's just getting started this is a good
barometer Dan to keep your eye on at our
forecast website for the Northeast about
where the soil temperatures are now this
was last week what was pretty what was
expected and in general while it was a
little bit above normal the majority of
the northern part of the Northeast
hasn't accumulated many growing degree
days at all and we don't expect to
accumulate many this week this was last
week and this is this week so we'll get
a few into the metropolitan New York
area but since mark but since March
first in northern climates you know
north of the Pennsylvania New York
border we haven't accumulated any base
50 growing degree days
since the beginning of March alright and
there's the growing degree day forecast
now what does this all mean there's
going to be very little progress of the
growing season in the Northeast this
coming week heck in upstate we're gonna
get some we're gonna get some snow in
many parts of upstate New York alright
so when we look at this one measure of
the potential of a cool season grass
plant to grow and you look at an average
temperature of 50 degrees which we're
not even getting to yet that mark will
gives us less than 25% of active growth
right we're not really getting much
active growth any mowing we're doing in
a lot of our northern areas could be
related to just cleaning up
recreational mowing keeping people busy
but if you're doing that we certainly
are promoting and we talked about last
week in this venue raising the height of
cut so we're not gonna go into the
mowing situation again we encourage it
last week pretty extensively in our
webinar with Bill another great Nebraska
faculty now one of the things that's
going on throughout you know sports
fields everywhere is you know spring
baseball would normally be happening and
again
the Ohio State University gave a good
recommendation get the conditioner off
loose material store it roll and firm
the dirt right just into the infill and
pull straight weeds and raking may be
needed now a lot of this can be minimal
if you did a good job of putting the
skin to get to bed well right if you
left it sort of in shambles last fall
now it's going to be tougher to get it
to minimal maintenance now but if it's
nice and clean now it would ought to be
pretty straightforward to keep it clean
and there's some simple things you can
do to manage that that's unique to the
sports fields now st ma has done a good
job and really relating a lot of great
information from practical users and i
stress this with every audience that i
talk to this particular high school turf
grass professor turfgrass science
professor did an excellent job about how
in talking to people about this issue
about moving traffic around about
coaching them and training them about
the way they like to learn and i think
this kind of been for me
is enormous ly valuable at this time
when a lot of communication is important
right no one's using the field what are
the realistic things we could be doing
out here so let me just finish up here
because this is the important stuff Rock
this is the stuff I know that you know
number one we've got a sports field
website number two this is the
cultivation practices that many wrote up
I know you've done a similar thing this
is the one on our sports field website
let's start our conversation here and
let's first off say you know this is
something that I've you know we write in
our on our website and a document a
little graphic about how it works in the
soil generally I think these benefits
are short-lived I want to talk a little
bit about I want to stop sharing my
screen and talk a little bit about there
we go and talk a little bit about what
you think about cultivation a lot of
guys are asking hey nobody's used in the
field can i cultivate so where do we
start with that well you know I think
it's an opportunity if we can find any
benefit in this mess we're currently in
and we do have some people locally I
mean we're worried about the same growth
stage you guys are surprisingly in the
middle of the United States still you
know we're barely starting to mow the
grass is barely starting to green up etc
we're a little bit further on growing
degree days and temperature but that
said you know since all the fields where
community sports are played the ball
fields or whatever those are pretty well
shut down but they're allowed to be
maintained and I have managers much like
you would ask any well should we do
something and we've got some fields that
rarely get cultivated and I see that as
a door opening for some batch management
and some cultivation management also
understanding that they don't have the
crew but nor do they have the necessity
to bang this out in you know 24 hours or
less so and get ready to play on so I'm
going to say those fields that have been
neglected for batch management and
cultivation management this is an open
door to get on those fields but if you
went into the winter with a field in
pretty good shape and you normally would
practice some sort of cultivation that
might me to feel my considered not
getting on immediately and working on
the ones that allow you the opportunity
that you know the heavy playfields the
youth fields that sort of stuff and if
they're all mostly native soil with some
sand based in your neck of the woods
right right okay so let's let's take
let's take each one at a time here let's
say there is a field that's a native
soil field and you know I got a guy or
two and I got one of those really gigs
with the you know the the just drug
things that go in you know yo big I'm
ready to do it what's the right tool now
in your opinion you know we've we're on
the record about hollow tine cultivation
in San based systems and golf courses
but we're talking about a little bit of
a different animal here so what's the
tool you might start with and how would
you approach it well I'm going to say
that the little whirligig thing that you
described as minimal use for actual
compaction alleviation it's a great
overseeing tool right
it's what's up the soil a little bit on
the surface Frank but at the end of the
day it really doesn't do much for
subsurface compaction and it makes you
feel good and maybe even people that
manage the fields say oh look they're
out there working but seriously you're
not doing much I'm especially now you
lender you under exaggerated a little
bit you know some of them do actually go
to like maybe two inches but they are so
superficial at best and if it's all you
can do and you're over seeding and
you're looking at thatch rather than
true cultivation for compaction
alleviation yeah but most of the time
they're really not that valuable except
in those instances I said so I'm not a
big fan of those I don't think those
drum-type
they don't have that high girl power
around and they don't have the power you
know I really prefer the more golf
course centric you know vertically
operated hollow tine in an instance with
a native soil field where you can pull
soil up and actually go to a certain
depth and even even deep tightening
those in our region at least a deep
diners are still out and doing it if you
have a field that has not seen
management and you've got a budget you
know once again these are all qualifiers
you know maybe you want to go in an
aggressively truly deep
they rather than the surface disruption
thing you do with those pull behind
non-driven time right sorry so so here's
the thing for us here in the Northeast
now Rock we just got a forecast this
morning that says we're in for anywhere
I would say from three-quarters of an
inch at the low end to as much as two
plus inches of rain over the next four
to five days let's think through the way
we approach cultivation from a soil
moisture perspective right so what kinds
of soil moisture conditions on these
neglected fields are going to be the
kinds of conditions I want to Drew these
practices well certainly not wet right
you know but the drier they are within
reason of keeping the plant alive the
drier they are the more apt you're going
to get to some in addition if you're
using a quarantine you know you'll get
some depth obviously but at the same
time you know you get some shattering
even with a slicer dying or a spoon
dying or a lot of the things like that
so you know you want them on the drier
side what do you think about what you
just described so you run it over a
field that's dry and then you get this
rain and you've got you know silty clay
loans or clay loans or whatever you have
in your region I'm thinking they leaned
towards the heavier side you know they
expand and then you've sort of lost what
you did so you're better off looking for
a time when you're gonna have a period
of dry drying or dry soil and then get
on them with these devices that are
actually benefit from the soil being a
little bit dry and literally shattering
it as they go in and out and moving
across okay so then let's talk about go
back to a tool now if I really like
shattering to me in a lot of these
native soils I think it's actually one
of the fundamental things that you know
will give you this widespread macro pore
flow if you hit it in the sweet spot if
you had to pick one thing would you take
Verta drain with a kick over a hollow
time pulling a core no doubt I would be
like on native soil fields I don't think
there's any question I believe that much
like you you know record it today
because I think we're in a hundred
percent agreement on this recorded today
I believe that that's where you get the
most benefit you get continuing
the pores from the surface you get a lot
of things going on that you don't get
with a single hollow tine you know that
and that kicks important and most of
these devices are designed to give you
kick and you can adjust it on some of
them but even a spoon time at a
different speed will give you a
different kick than one that you know
and another speed right so you want to
get as much kick as you honor and you
want the soil to be a little on the dry
side right you don't want it wet so what
about this new concoction the heir to G
I know Soraka has been playing around
with it have you paid attention at all
to that being a noninvasive certainly
it's slow and so in some cases it might
be good for targeted cultivation and
we're going to get the targeted
cultivation in a minute you don't have
to do an oil field maybe there's some
places where it needs it most air 2g
what do you think I think they just as
he just described it you know I almost
filled in the blanks there Frank because
I think that that you do see some
benefit this the speed of it which is
going to be less of an issue now and
we're not seeing play on the fields the
speed of it and I like that prescription
area cultivation you know if you have
enough we didn't generally do the whole
field in one method right we've got
these little areas that you can do
different things on if you have the
technology and and you know or the
contractor can come in and and do
targeted prescription cultivation sure I
think that there there could be some
value in there to G I have not seen the
data up close and personal so I'm not
ready to widespread say yeah that's the
device you want to use um but you know
Soraka is looking at it looking at it
fairly close and he's another one you
mentioned some earlier people premiere
people in sports turf obviously he's
another one of the rock stars and what
he's doing is you know usually he takes
the time and understands that and fully
exploit it researches it before he
starts making recommendations and you
know I don't think he's come out and
said yeah this is the new tool for the
Millennial it's this is the new tool
that we're looking at right yeah and I
did you see in that now let's go back
for a second to you know bringing up
soil for soil sake or hollow tine
cultivation how worried should I be in
general as a weed site as a fellow weed
scientist I know you are how worried
will I be about you know now my soil is
wet I'm
this is a good idea I'm gonna plan to do
it in this window in a few weeks if I'm
still not open bla bla bla how much do
we worry later we go with this to create
potential weed problems that's a great
question Frank because this is what if
you if you're on one of your higher
maintained fields and you've been
routinely applying pre-emergent and
doing broadleaf weed control I don't see
bringing soil to the surface as much of
a problem because over time you've
reduced the soil seed bank right and you
know I mean this is true in golf it's
true and sports turf but I worry about a
field that's on the margin that doesn't
get the aggressive pre-emergent
application or post-emergent control for
annual grasses or whatever the case may
be so you know laying underneath that
surface that's a full weed scientist
there is just a seed bank that's ready
to pop and I don't care whether it's
annual bluegrass or crabgrass or you
know you get loose grass open up in your
neck of the woods we are alarmingly
getting more and more further and
further north says Matt Elmore yes so
that's alarming because that's not a
weed you want because it requires a
whole different toolbox of herbicides to
actually in effective control and in
sports fields in our area this grass is
far more problematic than crabgrass
because it whose grass loves those
compacted soils right in front of gold
boxes you know in in the run-through on
first base we see goose if I want to
isolate it I'll go there first right
that's where you see it so so so those
are the kind of things that I would
worry about on a marginal field where
you're you haven't been maintaining it
at the level that you might your
championship field or whatever and
you're gonna bring up a ton of weed seed
when you do that and then also open it
up for any weak seed that blows in to
fall into this convenient hole that
doesn't collapse in on itself as quickly
as a spoon tine or a slicer tomato or
even a solid time right so let's talk
about a non-invasive way then before we
start taking a couple of questions the
airway we've we've been a fan and not a
fan and then a fan in some places of the
airway that stands behind a tractor it's
just these knives that go in and makes a
slit maybe four to six inches down I
think maybe
bit of shattering but the beauty of it
is in the in my mind the attraction
initially is you can do it really
rapidly and it seems to create a slit
now we had some problem on our finer
fields where it actually does a lot of
tearing and and seems to cause some sort
of browning but I wonder on these fields
that maybe don't get a lot of attention
now that we could spend some attention
on practice fields and otherwise well
how do you I know there's not a lot of
research in this area but I'm just
thinking about the time going in and
being really fast to do - now the area
or devices like lat the slicer time you
know I mean obviously if you can get it
in three to four to five inches that's
better than one to two because then we
you know create other issues you know
and minerally did some work I was at one
of the Iowa State field days when he was
still physically on campus and you know
he went to directions and everyone wants
to go perpendicular no you go in an
angle in your second pass right you know
his data show that you go as an angle
and you pick up more surface area as
well as more aggressively get better
aeration or whatever in the in the
subsurface in the subsoil so I thought
that was intriguing so he's like go at a
30 to the first pass not at a 90 but
when he said that on fields that were
you know typical recreational fields or
whatever he saw that open it up and then
he always you know he says if you're
gonna slice up a field you should always
throw out feed and I've always believed
that there's a reason for that as well
because even if you only get 20 percent
germination you got 20 percent
germination right and that seed that
wasn't there and especially on these
fields that are less so so I like the
use of a slicer time whether it's an
airway or whatever and you nailed it you
can get across a field you get in less
time than it takes to do a traditional
you know vertically operated hollow
dying or device like that right so you
can get on it and get on it frequently
too for that matter even if you're a
skeleton crew you know I see a few
things you know guys are still keeping
paint in their corner lines so they
don't have to redo the whole field
they're just going out on the fields and
putting into corner markers so that they
can string lines from there
so there's a lot of things guys even
with a small crew can do to save some
time do these sorts of things and then
the question of well you know I'm a
little bit further south I got a little
bit more money I got this unit
University field it is high in municipal
field should i core and consider san
topdressing I got this sand from last
year what do you like about slinging
sand on this native soil fields you know
we've caught him and we're starting and
thinking hey maybe this is a good time
to get him a sand cap on him what do you
like that approach throwing some sand at
this time I like sand camping if you're
committed to doing it forever if you're
committed to doing it once then that's a
horrible combination already you got to
put a cap on it and that cap has to be
developed over time and and you know we
didn't you know we always revert back to
the golf course trade right you know
they started with push up greens then
they started top dressing and it's not
until they get an official the layer of
sand on them so if this is something you
just want to do like in a short term and
not commit to it it's a horrible idea
that's so great
all right Carl we got any questions how
we doing doing great we have no
questions so maybe one thing I had a
question on it's a lot of people will
typically go out they'll do their core
cultivation or whatever cultivation
practice and then they'll go maybe throw
some seed and then fertilizer you know
thinking about the fertilizer part of
that now is that something you're gonna
need after you do this this cultivation
practice or can you say hey maybe I've
got a bunch of time and not have to
worry about I like that question only
because right now you really don't want
things growing as aggressively as you
normally would right so I'm gonna say
there's adequate soil nutrition to get
seed going and you know and then
hopefully this is going to break
sometime in the not-too-distant future
you know you said I think you said
something like late June or whatever you
know we're a little bit behind you in in
our region but you know we're looking at
probably August before we're gonna be
through our worst worst age we haven't
peaked yet in central United States so
we're gonna peak in about three weeks
with Koh bid nineteen so we're gonna be
a little bit later but still that said
I am NOT going to fertilize if if I
don't think it's absolutely necessary in
the field says to do it I think that
we're just inviting growth you've got a
limited crew you're gonna increase your
mowing and I'm sure you probably talked
about raising mowing Heights and maybe
the use of regulators you know flying
fertilizer and growth regulators it's
kind of contrary to each other so yeah I
would say yeah don't you'd normally put
down a starter and you'd normally push
it fairly hard because you want that
seed to get up and going but that's
because we want to get people on it no
longer have that problem right so I
would not unless something tells you you
have to more times than not you don't
need to put additional fertility don't
love the idea sling and seed rock I mean
you got bare ground throat a damn seed
it's got the best chance ever with
nobody playing around on it and you cut
and hire to me if you had chronic areas
this is where the targeted precision
thing comes from in my mind is this you
know Eagle mouths or where coaches and
players stand or you know wherever those
pinch points are you focusing in on
those areas with a guy or two you know
you can get a couple of gold mouths done
and if you know a day if you want to cut
it out and redo it or just sling some
seed as you're passing by no harm no
foul there right Rock well no exactly
right I'm a big fan and seed I mean I
know it adds to your budget but it's not
that expensive and you know I mean
seriously when you look at the other
things you do on a day to day basis it's
not really that expensive and I would I
would put even during regular play you
know under normal times I would be
throwing seed out and I you know people
say well you mean rye grass I'm not
talking about rye grass I'm talking
about you know so if you only get 10%
germination that's 10% more than you had
right and and so yeah I'm all for
throwing seed out at any time it was
interesting you know once again cruising
around with men or one time in Iowa and
we were taking compaction measurements
across these fields and the worst place
is where the players stand you know
nothing grows there and some people have
put carpet there don't leave me eight
that problem but that was and so I would
be throwing seed out there constantly
right now every time you do anything and
open it up even a little bit or bare oil
bearers like you said in front of gold
mouse or you know wherever it were that
you know between hash marks where you
know those
exist let's get it really dense turf
going there because you're gonna be
mowing higher just gonna get a really
nice root system on it because you're
mowing iron all the things that throw in
the agronomy of it that we ignore
because we're trying to maintain a slick
playing surface right right yeah throw
seed out no dad and and you know you
brought up one more thing Carl before we
go we're here at almost at the witching
hour and and the idea of cutting back
mowing rock to root deeper ties in with
one of the reasons we poke holes to
begin with if you can do that shattering
and combine it with mowing higher and
less frequently those roots will explore
the shattering that you do as deep as
you do it yes oh no no because you know
what do we tell our introductory
students where the roots grow and they
say soil notes say no they grew in the
air spaces in the soil I know that
sounds rudimentary but it's true if you
don't have air space you don't get
routing so those heavily targeted
prescription areas throw some feet out
get some kind of cultivation in native
soils a little bit drier is better and
don't really need to pull a core at this
point done excellent all right Carl I
see questions how we doing yeah we got a
good question from Neil at RIT so he's
asking I've got a natural soil field and
let's say I'm committed to to putting
the sand cap on it how much sand should
go down and then how many times per year
I guess you know how quickly can you do
that could you do that all at once right
now is that something you're gonna have
to consider over two or three years so
let's start with this rock I think we're
in agreement the caps got to be about
three to four inches maybe with a slit
drain or something underneath so I think
the the superintendent's out in Seattle
were able to put down an inch and a half
in a single year when they were trying
to fight worms years and years ago but
that was ridiculous
yeah was they were doing some smothering
and you know I mean like that's a lot of
sand and one you know and one in one
year even right you know so we we know
you're putting on about about an inch
with about 22 cubic yards on you know
our acuity feet sorry 4,000 per year so
if you wanted to put on an inch that's
what it's going to take if you wanted to
put on 2 inches it would take twice that
I'm not sure any term even under no play
conditions
I'm sure you've been aggressively with
that much sand on so you would have to
commit you want to have three to four
inches on the cap of course that's going
to change the contour and you're gonna
have to move it accordingly
especially in crown fields if you know
on a ground football field for example
some of the soccer fields obviously
that's less of an issue but still you do
want some slope on the surface to get
water off yeah you know that's important
you know native soil fields begin to
function by having a crown we many
people don't really think about this
anymore because we've had sand based
systems for so long that you don't see
the heavy Crown's like you used to so it
is important if you're gonna do some
capping that you know you do it in
relation to the subsoil like you would
do a putting surface and really for it
to function you got to have some some
drains along the side you got to have
some catch drains otherwise the place
where rock and I just said you get the
most traffic by the coaches is where
you're putting all the water if you
don't pick it up yeah it's gonna it's
just going to pawn there you're exactly
right and and you know the sand will
flow but you know that on that interface
in between it's gonna saturate top
before it goes below right so it sheets
off right and so you get on the side you
know eventually you'll get so much on
the surface and you know they'll there
will be some men are mixing and fruits
and so that you'll get stability on the
surface but that doesn't happen um you
know without several years of aggressive
top dressing probably multiple you know
or removal if you want to do it more
aggressively drier soils you could
probably solid sign it and get there
just just as quick because I'm a big fan
of using the solid line even on native
fields when they're dry not when we have
the moisture issues we talked about
right alright Carl how are we doing
questions good no more questions I think
we're right at right at half an hour so
you know classes thirty minutes and turf
I think we're calling it so much for
joining us you happy to do anything Carl
yep right back here next week
thank you ready take care this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu